[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whether you believe it or not the world
around you is filled with strange
phenomena that science has yet to
explain and in those unfortunate moments
when people come face-to-face with them
they are helplessly thrown into the dark
depths of fear but there are those who
choose to fight against the darkness
every day shining a ray of hope into
that chaos these Warriors opposing the
shadows are called psychics regular
Tucker so let's set this job now the fee
for my services will depend on which
course of exorcism you pick which course
option a the trial course gets you 20%
of option B the serious course gets you
50% an option C the all-out course gets
you a 99% spirit reduction 100%
guaranteed certain restrictions apply
reduction how should I put this spirits
are kinda like carbon dioxide so you're
saying they're poisonous it's mono oxide
I mean they occupy a sort of gaseous
space makes it a bit difficult to
completely get rid of one that said have
no fear if it comes back I'll get rid of
it for 20% off might you be oh he's my
boyfriend
listen up this is all super shady Hanako
you should really reconsider this super
shady huh yes I can't blame you for
feeling that way I mean all that stuff
about nightmares and ghosts what stupid
story just leave everything to me if I
exorcise the spirit
I'm sure hanukkah's face will return to
normal - I see so you've been having
these dreams since you walked through
that abandoned building last week yes
that's right they're so scary and creepy
here we are Regan it's that building
over there it's right over here
hold up did you just point at the wrong
building so it's that one funny story
and immense aura was coming from that
other building too these things happen
nature of the biz it gets confusing with
all these evil spirits in the world you
know there's no way ghosts are hanging
around everywhere close calls you can't
be too careful these days
a bunch in Dublin what are you eight
years old your mouth taro you're being
rude
he's the one who's being rude here
making fun of people's looks no now
Chanukah there are old people like him
silly sceptics anyway shall we go they
say this place is haunted by the angry
spirit of a man who saw a cockroach get
it crit you believe that horse crap
I see everything's becoming so clear
he's so serious all of a sudden could
there really be I'm getting creepy vibes
even someone like me might not be able
to handle it psychic how would you like
me to haunt your dreams too
maybe I'll use my curse and crash both
your heads through the ceiling actually
appear this is one of Reagan's special
attacks where he violently throws table
salt everywhere this is just regular old
salt you buffoon if it's not purified
it's not gonna work
impossible I heard that spirits were
totally weak against any kind of salt
well if salt won't melt this guy down
I'll just call my ultimate weapon hey
mom sorry do you think you could swing
by being serious here evil spirits right
in front of me the client in the evil
spirit are both waiting so you'll need
to hurry okay cool thanks
hey Bob we were waiting for you hmm
so after the salt you're sending in a
middle schooler
[Music]
he is Chagall Kageyama also known as mob
an actual psychic mentoring under the
questionable expertise of Reagan erotica
who also happens to be the protagonist
of this story master I asked you not to
summon me on such short notice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh man you're a lifesaver
never felt that evil spirit would
actually show up here you are pay for
the day oh thank you that one today was
just a lower level spirit so I really
shouldn't be paying you more than half
today I'm a nice guy
think of your full pay as a bonus right
hmm what's wrong are you not okay with
that
oh no just don't know why you called me
to handle such a weak spirit I just
don't get it when you're into my level
you get so crazy strong you want up
melting everyone around you during a
simple exorcism that's why I asked you
to take care of the weaker ones really
if you say so I'm also not quite sure
what you mean by melt either well of
course you don't idiot that's because
you lack training you need to learn all
you can from me your master your powers
are meant to be used not doing so it
being wasted working for me and gives
you the opportunity to help other people
and continue training at the same time
two birds one stone but if you miss you
as a power such as yours it can only
lead to your own self-destruction that's
why I'm teaching you how to control your
powers you don't want them to go berserk
do you remember your promise you will
not use your psychic powers against
other people
there you go again always spending
spoons you really need to stop doing
that it's a bad habit oh come now my
dear she jo is going through puberty a
young man should be able to bend a spoon
from time to time right sorry
and there you go spoiling the boy again
you need to learn a thing or two for
each soup she gave he got another
perfect score on his quiz today
come on mom anyone can do that listen if
you ever need someone to talk to let me
know I'll always be there for my big
brother thanks I appreciate it will do
and now you're spoiling him as well read
soon and next one you bin gets replaced
using your allowance you hear huh sorry
dude tough break here on your own when
it comes to what mom tells you now
you're in a real pickle arches again
[Music]
so if BOM is as cute as ever today okay
class so what would be the answer for
this one let's go with Kageyama yes sir
I have no idea if you can't solve this
that would mean the only thing you know
how to do is addition you were asleep
weren't you forget it sit down please
[Music]
hello Bob how goes it sorry to call you
two days in a row but could you come
down to the station right now sure what
for well we've got another job and it's
a big one right okay see you soon
today's job is from a local neighborhood
council it's over at Ho Nadeau tunnel
along the old highway it's a famous
haunted place
the tunnels always had some shady
stories and now it's been closed for
years the bad rumors just won't go away
also a number of college students and
bloggers have gone there to snoop around
a little bit when missing lightly
contributing to those rumors and this is
the kicker so it's the site of a huge
group accident yeah the incident
occurred about 30 years ago from what it
says here more than 20 people died at
once the bitter hatred of all those
people must be swirling around that
tunnels
stay on your toes mom never know what
might happen oh right
this is it
well let's take a look around i
reagan-era taka a new star of the
paranormal world will clean this place
up we're gonna exorcise every last one
of them what are you doing student
you're coming too how do we pad up the
Suncoast town mum are you listening
I'm gonna go melt down a big one so
follow me okay
sure if you want you seem to have it
under control so I didn't think that
you'd need my help yet I mean this is
nothing really
what stick with me so you can learn
something you're amazing master Oh I
mean this tunnel actually seems pretty
dangerous I can sense the presence of a
very powerful spirit further down
usually haunted spots like these end up
being fake but this time it's definitely
the real deal if a normal person
happened to anger the spirit in here
what would happen they'd never make it
out in one piece
of course they wouldn't that's why you
and I are going to exercise it alright
here we go let me take the lead I'll be
counting on you to support me however
you can from behind right it's kind of
chilly down here yes it is great we
forgot to bring flashlights with us
master don't you feel something hmm well
it is pretty humid in here
no I'm talking about auras oh right that
my nose is a little stuffy today so does
that have anything to do with sensing
auras when you get to my level it does
do you feel anything down here at all
feeling anything would be an
understatement
there are 1218 no wait
I'd say even more than that right nearby
us oh it looks like we're being
surrounded they're going to attack us
now alright I'll leave a small fry to
you go mob
[Music]
man that's a lot of noise they're really
strong aren't they boom we were a couple
of normal people we might have been in
real danger
oh well I'm pretty sure that took care
of all of them another piece of Kalibak
there's someone right in front of me oh
[Music]
it's just a wrestler screwing around in
the dark don't scare me like that I
thought you were an evil spirit go
practice somewhere else Master I'm sure
you sensed it but the boss of the evil
spirits is over there so watch out okay
[Music]
hmm so you're the boss here huh you
would have tried to disguise yourself as
a wrestler but you can't fool me you try
start in this tunnel when my biker gang
and I were driving through it the guy in
front of you
that I'm their leader listen up this
tunnel is my turf now oh gosh every last
intruder here we go
what my ignition attack this isn't
working
a force field no way [ __ ] it this power
be coming from someone like him too late
for regrets now spirit the moment you
tried to take on the genius psychic
Reagan our attack up
what's the moment your fate was sealed
door cannot be exercised this is one of
Reagan's special attack straight punches
the enemy with his fist covered in table
salt oh dear
so you are a fake
go back to the ozone layer hey what are
you doing Bob
hurry up and melt them already hold on a
minute master let's hear him out first
sure I'm act tough
but neither me nor my gang are anything
compared to the evil spirit down the
tunnel we've been getting orders from
him all these years and that's why we've
been scaring people that go down here do
you think you can fool the likes of
Regan with such lies so your big plans
to try to make us pity you don't let him
fool you mob those are nothing but the
typical lives of a con artist
meltem before that I'm gonna go have a
look it's a little weird that the aura I
felt before coming in here hasn't
disappeared yet something's still not
right I thought so too
no matter how strong that kid may be
that thing is an evil spirit that's
lived on this valley for hundreds of
years everyone that's died here was
killed by a mule others dad
so you guys were also killed by no like
I said we just happened to slip on a
banana peel
hey Bob come back you listening to me
come back
[Applause]
oh you're safe
yeah that evil spirit wasn't very
powerful huh oh I'm nobody
you idiot so mom and you want a student
of the new star of the paranormal world
or you're gonna oh right sir
I thank you mom now the death specters
gang could leave this tunnel and pass on
this voice Oh could this be yours huh
all right here we go bossman
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
now we can depart to the afternoon
[Music]
Bob our work here is done
let's go right by the way master why
didn't you do anything back there didn't
I tell you from the beginning that I'd
leave the small fries to you
[Music]
what do you want to do
sorry to keep you waiting
shall we sure so cuz ramen work for you
huh alright well if you're gonna add on
chashu pork limited to two
[Music]
a group of telepaths suddenly appear in
disturbed mobs daily life having doubts
about his peaceful youth mob heads into
a world of women where's the coal which
weighs tomorrow next time I'm ups like a
100 episode 2 notes about youth the
telepathy Club appears watching it in
real time wise decision
[Music]
[Applause]